the prime minister's accused of not
taking the concerns of
mp safety appropriately seriously he
called it humbug do you agree that it's
humbug
as i said the prime minister can speak
for himself
well i mean he's not answering any of
these questions i'm asking you do you
think it's humble do you think mps are
unsafe
as a result of i think mp's safety is as
a cause
of concern you're in my job now what
would you do i'll answer my question
would you yeah absolutely do you think
it's a you're thinking you know it's
it's not a laughing matter
coming up of concern do you think it's
labour mps or
any mp safety is the amount of concern
are you responsible for whipping up an
atmosphere
of uh atmosphere of danger for mps with
a rhetoric that you and the prime
minister are responsible for
that answer the question
the pr all right let's try different one
will the prime minister be obeying the
law mr gummings
all governments obey the law or they try
to so will the prime minister be obeying
the ban act
what did i just say so i could take oh
that's good so i take from that the
prime minister is going to be
obeying them is going to obey the ben
act
so he's going to be he's going to be
sending if there's no deal by october
the 17th he'll be sending that letter
to the european council is that correct
we can take it from your answer they'll
explain what he's doing on the 17th
on the 19th of october when we get there
but mps are very keen to know the
answers in my question
they're all sort well indeed there are
democratic electoral representatives for
whom i'm sure that you have the utmost
respect as do i so
will the prime minister be writing that
letter the prime minister will make
clear
what he's going to do at the right time
but shouldn't i mean it shouldn't really
be a matter of debate should it he'll
he'll be writing this i think you
understand anything about negotiations
if you think that
well it doesn't really matter does it
because the law is the law is the law of
the land
you don't seem to know whether you're
trying to answer ask me questions or
whether to interrupt all the time all
right okay
i won't interrupt uh in follow-up to
this will the prime minister on october
the 17th
if he hasn't got a deal be writing a
letter to the european council asking
for an extension of article 50 yes or no
you're confused about the date you don't
even know the basics of the subject that
you're asking about
late october late october the prime
minister is supposed to be happening to
do you know what date the benefits are
supposed to be having to ask for another
you know what
i've talked about the european council
october the 17th and shortly after that
if there is no deal what dates are
shortly after
shortly after early october but i forget
the exact date obviously in my head but
you know you know you know as well as i
do that is in late october so let's not
try and be
another clueless journalist another
clueless journal no no it's not
a stupid question to ask whether or not
the prime minister is obeying the law is
it mr cummings let me ask you another
question
uh the uh defeat you had on the supreme
court this week
uh was that all part of your master plan
11 nil over the propagation of
parliament
i don't have a master plan really
because people say you do well people
say all sorts of things
you say all sorts of things you don't
know what you're talking about right so
everyone watching at home should know
don't watch the news because it's almost
is it really yeah
and why is that well because i have
people like you on asking questions and
you don't even know it's the 17th of
october 19th of october
well i know i'm sure you're very very
active
it's just very very interesting to know
just exactly whether or not the prime
minister's gonna be obeying the law i
mean we can get into kind of you know
one-upmanship about this but i actually
think it's really really serious if the
prime minister of this country
is actually trifling and suggesting he
might not obey the law so you can get
all funny with me about whether i know a
particular day or not but i think it's
really really important
whether or not the prime minister this
country is going to obey the law because
if he doesn't obey the law then i might
not choose to obey the law tonight
nobody might choose to obey that
i don't think that's the right attitude
you don't just watch criminals and then
say oh you're going to become a criminal
but that's exactly what the president's
exactly the point that's what toddlers
exactly and the prime minister talking
you're talking like a toddler the prime
minister
is the one who is saying that he's not
going to obey the law so if the prime
minister the person
who with the highest political and legal
office in the land isn't choosing
to obey is suggesting that he might not
obey the law why the hell should any of
the rest of us answer me that mr
cummings
would you not have an answer i i think i
think you're not a very good journalist
mate
really well i don't really care what you
think i care far more about the future
of the country and whether or not the
prime minister
is going to obey the law is he going to
obey the law or not you've already asked
that question i
already said so is he going to write the
letter this clown what's he like eh
i don't care whether or not you're in
zombies i can get this what you think of
me i'm just asking
a very basic question i've already said
and i don't think you can you're so
panicky
and you're talking so much you can't
listen to what's being said to you
i've i've listened to everything i said
ten minutes ago
of course the prime minister will obey
the law that's what all governments do
so he's gonna that's what this guy's
writing the letter it has no deal
well you're talking about the ben act
we'll see what we do about the banach
when we get to the right date
that you don't know the date though do
you think that it's due do you think
it's another day i think it's
do you think it's do you think that it
is uh is it the 17th or 19th
do you think that it is or are they do
you think that do you think you've got a
way around the
if you're going to get something if
you're going to do interviews why don't
you actually research what you're
talking about before you come out here
and you would look like such a joke okay
do you think that
uh the ban act is a piece of law that
you'll have to follow or do you think
that there is a loophole in it
well there are obviously loopholes in it
because the remain lawyers are all
babbling away on twitter about the
loopholes
so they've said themselves that they're
loopholes
so you think you're going to be able to
exploit a loophole i didn't say that